[Musique]
pour un réseau rei seulement voilà je
prends un tir farm badeni
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors là aujourd'hui banques on peut
comme d'habitude annaba en coupant de m
et on empile
en fait ça bouge beaucoup donc c'est
assez physique donc moi ça me plaît
sandrine l'amour est une ancienne
chômeuse de longue durée
sandrine a retrouvé du travail grâce à
une démarche originale pour lutter
contre le chômage
le dispositif territoire 0 chômeurs de
longue durée
j'ai beaucoup fait m'a travaillé sur le
verre de gt enchaîne en usine oui je
fais ça peu près pendant dix ans
j'ai fait beaucoup d'un camion j'ai eu
des contrats en cdd et là on a un cdi
on peut voir dans la vie on est sûr
d'avoir un salaire à la fin du mois et
puis on sait que nous on a pas mal de
boulot au bois donc attention
[Musique]
l'idée est simple plutôt que de dépenser
de l'argent pour aider les personnes
privées d'emploi nouveau financer de
nouveaux emplois utiles à la
collectivité
objectif proposer un cdi à chaque
chômeur de longue durée en 2016
dix territoires pilotes se sont lancés
dans une expérimentation sur cinq ans à
l'automne 2020
le parlement a voté l'extension du
projet à 50 nouveaux territoires
c'est un dispositif qui est issu d'une
loi de 2016 qui était portée par laurent
quand guillaume et et qui était insufflé
par atd quart monde sur la base de trois
principes un nul mais tin employables 2
il ya une foultitude de travaux qui
peut-être ne sont pas rentables donc
n'intéresse pas l'économie de marché et
3 finalement ce qu'on appelle les
dépenses pas si c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui ne travaillent pas dès lors qu'on le
met au travail notamment en contrat à
durée indéterminée le coup s'équilibrent
entre le lait de subventions qu'on peut
avoir sur ce poste et finalement ce
qu'on donnerait à cette personne si elle
ne travaillait pas voilà le triptyque
qui composent cette expérimentation
[Musique]
il
prémery dans la nièvre fait partie des
dix territoires pilotes en 2016
notre caméra avait filmé les débuts du
projet et rencontrer david au chômage
depuis plusieurs années
de 47 ans se soit ils gagnent pu ou
pourront jamais trop tard et me suis
toujours dit je viens je m'inscris je
suis ce que je dois faire mais je me
suis toujours démarqué par ma main
[Musique]
bon
merci depuis trois ans david un cdi
il travailla le b e 58 une entreprise à
but d'emplois
c'est la structure qui porte le projet
territoire zéro chômeur à prémery
maintenant un atelier vélo quand j'étais
petit j'allais habitions à 93 réparer
les vélos de mes potes je rêve aller je
répare et le vélo les mobylettes
mais moi je travaillais à imerys toiture
à gros sous après j'ai eu un accident de
voiture donc j'arrête de travailler et
je suis resté cinq ans sans pareil
d'envoi cinq ans j'aurais cherché du
travail si c'est dur parce que pas de
voiture donc pas de voiture pas de
déplacement ça peut que vous habitez
dans un petit bled paraît donc bien non
j'ai pas pu charger travail donc ça
c'était telle aubaine
un travail qui tombait à la 100 à 200 m
de chez moi fallait pas rater ça sent
plus grands
[Musique]
vous travaillez pas vous rentrez chez
vous êtes chez vous vous sentez inutile
vous savez rien papel saharien puis
travaille pas tel qu'on est arrivé dans
la cinquantaine vous dit ça y est c'est
marrant on veut puis moi cher à face à
l'eshs mieux maintenant qu'est ce qui a
changé pour vous depuis vous travailler
ici le moral surtout le moral quoi lui
bien bossé
bon j'avais un salaire qui tombent tous
les mois
je répare corrige marqué à l'autre des
sages tout seul après sur les meubles je
marque pas ce qu'il ya à faire dessus
puis dans quel service il doit aller
pour être pour la réparation pas mignon
ça me met dans une vidéo sur youtube
mais après les goûts et les couleurs ça
se discute pas pour moi les valeurs
fondamentales du social c'est de tenir
debout et quand on tient debout c'est
qu'on est entre guillemets dans un
paysage qui est classique et
effectivement le paysage classique c'est
le travail avec une vie de famille bien
entendu un en tout cas ça constitue une
partie de de la vision qu'on peut avoir
pour que les gens tiennent debout d'un
point de vue social 90 ancien chômeur
travail tu as le pe sur une dizaine
d'activités comme le bûcheronnage le
maraîchage une recyclerie ou des
services aux habitants
ces emplois sont subventionnées par
l'état à hauteur de 18 mille euros par
an et par poste
en france la privation d'emploi
coûterait chaque année plus de 40
milliards d'euros selon les ong atd
quart monde
cette somme comprend les dépenses
sociales comme le versement du rsa
elle inclut aussi les coûts indirects
qui résulte des dégâts liés au chômage
sur la santé le logement ou la
protection de l'enfance elle comprend
les coûts d'accompagnement vers l'emploi
des personnes qui en sont éloignées
enfin elle intègre le manque à gagner
fiscal ou en matière de cotisations pour
l'état le principe réorienter une partie
de ces coûts vers la création de
nouveaux emplois
en s'appuyant localement sur des
structures dédiées les entreprises à but
d'emploi les oeufs bio et proposer un
cdi à chaque chômeur de longue durée le
coût du chômage longue durée en france
pour l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
c'est environ 18000 euros par an et par
personne ça c'est le coût supporté par
la collectivité en haut du fait que la
personne n'a pas d'emploi le coût d'un
emploi rémunéré au smic c'est environ
20000 euros
donc quand vous déjà vous dites ça ou
d'un côté à 18 le deuxième amis donc on
doit pouvoir faire quelque chose eh bien
c'est ce qu'ont fait puisqu'on créés
dans les territoires des activités qui
n'existe pas donc à une concurrence
personnes
elle ne percute pas un emplois existants
on prend les 18000 euros c'est le coût
du chômage en dur et qui nous est versée
par l'état pour financer une partie de
l'emploi que l'on va créer et donc ainsi
permettre à une personne qui était au
chômage de retrouver un emploi
et petit à petit on essaie de développer
des activités
voilà qui vont créer un chiffre
d'affaires suffisant donc c'est assez
simple ça s'est transformé à coup en
investissement
et si c'est mon quartier c'est où
j'habite depuis maintenant presque une
cinquantaine d'années j'arrivais ici en
j'avais 8 ans oui c'est un quartier que
j'aime énormément
là on va au 26 rue chevaleret c'est
là-bas que j'embauche tous les matins
aller à tout
[Musique]
alors cyclo logisticiens c'est comme un
chauffeur-livreur sauf que tout se fait
à vélo l'a tout simplement ça demande un
peu plus organisation parce que là il
faut être précis parce que bon il n'y a
pas de moteur même si on a de
l'assistance électrique sur les vélos
mais voilà si on pénale pas ça démarre
pas bruno petit phare travail a trait à
venir l'entreprise à but d'emplois créés
en 2017 dans le xiiie arrondissement de
paris
mais l'on son répondeur ouais ça rend
jissah lucie bruneau ouest appellent
pour savoir si c'est toi qui fais la
conciergerie avenue de france on avait
développé pas mal de services pour les
entreprises c'est un quartier très riche
le sud-est du 13e avec des pme des
grandes voilà des grandes entreprises
sur le sur l'avenue de france donc on
développe des services autour de la
qualité de vie au travail des services
de conciergerie d'entreprise des
services de livraison à vélo ça fait une
bonne vingtaine d'années que le kart il
en train de changer
nouvelle tour immeuble rénové
moi quand je suis arrivé c'était ouais
c'était au secours
ah ouais moi je suis arrivé les lélés
l'ailé les voyous ce n'était pas les hip
hop ou les trucs à ça c'était les
blousons noirs
berk a trait à venir travaille aussi
avec d'autres associations du quartier
tous les jeudis bruno et son collègue
nicolas enlève des invendus dans une
grande surface destinée à un foyer de
l'armée du salut
alors là on est chez ton frère
tout récent partenariat il ya des pommes
aubergines tomates salade iceberg
radi c'est vraiment varié ces archives
c'est super bien dans le 13e ont fait la
preuve aussi que cette expérimentation
elle a du sens en milieu urbain que
voilà même dans une grande ville comme
paris où il ya beaucoup de gens il ya
beaucoup de services qui existent déjà
et bien il reste des services innovants
inventé et puis surtout il ya plein de
personnes avec des compétences voilà qui
sont volontaires a travaillé qu'ils
trouvent pas forcément leur place sur le
marché de l'emploi
et
entre milieu rural et l'urbain et très
urbain puisque vous avez parlé de paris
xiiie on a reçu effectivement une baie
de l'île qui avait deux expérimentations
une peu une expérimentation dans une
tour puis une expérimentation dans un
quartier je fais volontairement ceci n'a
pas ce qu on était sur l'horizontalité
sur et sur la verticalité
on a des choses qui sont très
différentes et c'est le but de
l'expérimentation
[Musique]
trémery était la capitale du charbonnage
de bois c'étaient les usines lambiotte
et jusque dans les années 80 embauches
et 950 personnes et la population de
priorité de 2900 personnes et petit à
petit l'entreprise at elle quitté
jusqu'au dernier point qui s'écroulait
en 2002 150 emplois au tapis donc
comment est une ville sinistrée
et petit à petit on s'aperçoit que ça
revient alors c'est ça n'a pas été
facile les municipalités successives y
ont mis du leur mais là on a un
environnement favorable qui fait qu' on
a envie de vivre après mu alors bien sûr
la commune de primes en est un atout
économique
on s'est rendu compte que c'était
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
d'avoir une entreprise de cette taille
parce que finalement c'est la première
entreprise aujourd'hui de prémery et les
personnes perçoivent un salaire
je ne dirai partout ce salaire est
réinvesti localement mais une bonne
partie est investie économiquement à
prémery dans les commerces
ce commerce de proximité pas des
prairies quoi qui ont le mérite d'avoir
ouvert ce magasin libre-service
bonjour la stagiaire depuis
l'installation de lever eu 58 un magasin
d'alimentation ainsi que deux
boulangeries ont réinvesti le centre
ville il ya aujourd'hui dix territoires
qui expérimentent sont les dix premiers
territoires qui ont été choisi suite à
la loi de 2016 dans certains territoires
les entreprises que nous avons créés
sont devenues les premières entreprises
du territoire en nombre d'emplois pour
exemple concret après une ride dans la
nièvre
l'entreprise a plus d'emploi embaucher
une centaine de personnes c'est devenu
la première entreprise du territoire en
nombre d'emplois dans un territoire qui
a été d industrialiser en 2002 comme
quoi donc c'est possible de créer je
dirais des on peut lire un écosystème de
recréer un écosystème local là où il a
souffert et peut-être même de guérir un
territoire quelque part par l'action du
territoire
[Musique]
merci de gagny
réunion à la mairie de prémery avec
jacques legrain conseiller départemental
et thierry guyot chef d'entreprise et
président de le bo 58
ils font partie du comité local pour
l'emploi l'instance qui dans chaque
territoire rassemble les élus
entreprises demandeurs d'emploi et
acteurs sociaux pour piloter le projet
zéro chômeur elle définit les activités
de l'entreprise afin qu'elle réponde aux
besoins du territoire
il sent que on a un rôle à jouer pour le
territoire 6-1 permettre à nos salariés
nouveaux salariés de pouvoir
le rôle du comité légal c'est forcément
de deux d'avoir un regard sur les
activités de l'entreprise d'avoir deux
d'être sûr qu'on n'est pas en
concurrence avec avec les locaux parce
que c'est important de ne pas faire
concurrence aux activités aux artisans
et commerçants locaux
dans chaque territoire il ya un comité
local c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs la
force du projet dès le départ ont créé
un comité local dans lequel il y à des
acteurs publics la mairie par exemple
des acteurs privés des entreprises des
artisans des commerçants des grands
groupes
donc tous ces acteurs là pour travailler
ensemble pour définir quelles vont être
les activités qu'on va développer dans
quel cadre
on va créer une entreprise une
association par exemple là et puis quels
sont les emplois que l'on va créer en
partant des compétences des personnes
aidées ce qu'elle veut le faire on voit
que les territoires où ça fonctionne
c'est ce qu'ils sont capables
justement de mettre autour de la table
de toutes les parties prenantes et puis
où les relations entre entre ces
personnes là soit relativement fluide on
a observé des petits mecs assez
logiquement des tensions entre comités
locaux et entreprises à but d'emploi
parce que justement les comités locaux
étaient à ses partisans embaucher
rapidement les chômeurs de longue durée
et puis les responsables des entreprises
disait parfois ou là soyons prudents
parce que voici j'embauche les personnes
je ne pourrais pas toujours je ne serai
pas toujours comment les occuper on va
pas on va pas pouvoir répondre à leurs
attentes
porté par l'ambition de proposer un
travail à chaque chômeur sur leur
territoire les entreprises à but
d'emploi ont connu une croissance très
rapide
celle ci les a mises devant des
difficultés en 2019 un rapport
commandité par le ministère du travail
pointe une grande instabilité de
l'organisation du travail à prémery et
constate une situation dégradée
face à des salariés plus difficile à
encadrer que dans une entreprise
classique
je crois que pour beaucoup on était
vraiment des utopistes et donc les
personnes qui se sont engagées dans
cette dynamique n'avait pas forcément vu
que ce n'était pas forcément dans leurs
préoccupations de base le bus était en
offres d emploi oui mais offrir des
emplois et sa demande effectivement une
organisation un quart et qu' on ne
pilote pas une entreprise de 80 salariés
comme aux pilotes une entreprise de cinq
mâts manioli et moi on est d'accord je
lui ramène sa baignoire
les gens vous avez 50 ans
sinon on va tous les autres sinon je
vois pas tout son coeur
vasic hélas pour moi ça va pas faire pas
ton temps super bon avec pratiquement le
responsable technique
je suis éducateur technique spécialisé
je gère tout ce qui apparaît j'essaie
d'amener des outils pour eux
voilà je vais faire dans l'esprit des
pantins d'expérimentation mais il y
avait l'idée qu'on pouvait peut-être
faire émerger des entreprises avec un
autre mode d'organisation que les
entreprises classiques sans trop dire
archi avec une espèce de manège nantes
horizontale on va dans les faits on
s'est rendu compte que ça marche est
moyennement qu'en fait ce qu'on a quand
même des entreprises qui ont émergé sur
des territoires qui sont passés en
quelques mois de 0 salariés à des
dizaines de salariés voire une centaine
de salariés
quand vous n'avez aucun management
intermédiaire et que vous avez un stade
directeur qui va manager cet ensemble là
forcément vous êtes exposés à des
problèmes
pour répondre à ces problèmes de
management le bo 58 à renforcer son
équipe d'encadrement et elle va investir
dans la formation de ses salariés pour
les faire monter en compétences cette
stratégie de la formation est également
employé à paris au sein de lober trait à
venir bruno et nicolas dépose les
invendus au foyer de l'armée du salut
dans le même bâtiment
d'autres salariés de lober eux sont en
plein chantier le foyer abritera bientôt
un espace de coworking destinée aux
habitants du quartier est géré par trait
à venir ça va être un lieu il y aura un
petit y aura des petites sein de deux
réunions il y aura des des plans de
travail avec des ordinateurs dessus
aussi un gros chantier moi je trouve
c'est la première fois qu'on fait un
truc comme ça
ramzy et hama ont été formés par des
professionnels pour mener à bien le
chantier
quand j'ai vu que j'arrivais ici mais
j'ai commencé par la menuiserie j'ai
fait c'est un an un an et demi mais
jamais des trucs aussi balèze quoi et
les petit à petit on a appris et c est
vraiment plus professionnel maintenant
ici à la base on avait prévu ça avant le
premier confinement mais ça devait être
une salle petite salle de réunion avec
une table au milieu
après il ya ce côté là
ce maître l'espace détente mois que ce
que j'ai aimé la caisse qu'on savait pas
faire c'est l assemblage ça veut dire
faire des coupes avec la cie japonaise
les deux sont coupées ce lait de coupe
comme ça cela ne coupe comme ça et une
autre qui va se poser ici il est coupé
pour rentrer comme ça au milieu en fait
pour encastrer au départ nous avons pas
suffisamment pensés la carte de
formation mais on s'en est rendu compte
très rapidement
donc nous avons pris en compte beaucoup
plus cette question au coeur du projet
nous avons aujourd'hui développer des
formations sur toutes les activités qui
sont développés dans le projet et qui
permettent de faire monter en
compétences les personnes la montée en
compétences de ses salariés soulève la
question des parcours professionnels
quelles perspectives doit-on proposé aux
personnes embauchées par les entreprises
à but d'emplois tout le monde n'a pas la
même vision des choses pour certains ce
dispositif vise à ce que les gens soient
en cdi reste mais pour d'autres il faut
que ça soit des sorties positives dire
qu on est sur un cdi mais derrière on va
faire autre chose donc ça c'est un
impensé à mon avis de l'expérimentation
est ce qu on veut que ces personnes
restent à vie dans les entreprises
habite d'emploi ou alors est-ce qu'on
veut effectivement de les amener vers un
autre dispositif qui soit un dispositif
de droit commun une entreprise classique
une association une collectivité etc
à l'unanimité sénat et l'assemblée
nationale ont voté la poursuite de
l'expérimentation territoire zéro
chômeur il s'agit bien d'un texte
nécessaire dans la période d'incertitude
que nous connaissons et de difficultés
accrues pour les plus fragiles
son adoption est dans l'intérêt de tous
et dans l'intérêt de nos territoires
nous parlons d'un public qui est
particulièrement atteint socialement
économiquement et aussi
psychologiquement parce que nous parlons
de femmes et d'hommes qui connaissent le
chômage de longue durée
la nouvelle loi va permettre à 50
territoires supplémentaires de se lancer
dans l'aventuré est défini le rôle des
collectivités locales et notamment des
départements dans le financement de ses
nouveaux projets malgré les aides de
l'état
le dispositif est aujourd'hui
déficitaire
l'expérimentation menée depuis 2016 n'a
pas permis de démontrer la neutralité
financière qui en était le postulat de
départ
le dispositif a bien un coup qui
pourrait être considérable s'il devait
être développée à grande échelle
le regard que nous porterons sur cette
expérimentation ne doit pas pour autant
s'arrêter à cette réalité rappelle quand
même qu'on a des budgets qui sont
relativement est considérablement
déséquilibré notamment avec la crise
sanitaire et c'est aussi notre travail
que de regarder cet aspect là pour
équilibrer le modèle les porteurs de
l'expérimentation espérait atteindre un
certain niveau de chiffre d'affaires par
personne est en fait donc de l'or de
mémoire c'était de leur de 8000 euros
par part par personne on est plutôt à
3000 euros donc une espèce de déficit on
va dire par rapport au chiffre
d'affaires attendu est ce que c'est
parce que ben on n'a pas laissé assez de
temps aux entreprises pour atteindre ce
chiffre d'affaires ou est ce que c'est
que structurellement les ob eux
s'engagent dans des activités où c'est
difficile de produire du chiffre
d'affaires et peut-être ses 8000 euros
ils seront jamais à temps
sur les dix entreprises à but d'emploi
lancées depuis 2016 seuls trois sont
aujourd'hui à l' équilibre mais la
question du coup fait débat car pour les
défenseurs de l'expérimentation
les bénéfices du projet ne sont pas tous
mesurable avec des chiffres on ne peut
pas avoir que des indicateurs plus loin
on peut pas avoir que des chiffres dans
des politiques territoriales c'est ce
serait nier la valeur des gens comment
escrocs chiffres le fait qu' on vit
quand même mieux quand son voisin et vit
bien
cette redistribution cette contribution
au développement de l'emploi c'est aussi
finalement une rémunération de l'état à
cette bo qui est la seule à faire
ce qui est la seule à créer de l'emploi
non délocalisable à l'endroit où il n'y
en avait pas
[Musique]
en quatre ans près de 1000 anciens
chômeurs de longue durée ont été
embauchés en cdi dans le cadre de cette
expérimentation
une goutte d'eau comparé aux chiffres du
chômage de masse mais pour sandrine
david et bruno cela a tout changé
j'ai acheté une voiture elle j'ai acheté
un petit c4 pas trop cher ah oui je veux
la session travail en a un salaire donc
on peut faire des petits projets il ya
beaucoup moins surpris lorsqu'on va
travailler quoi ou à qui personne
traîner dans les rues les gens qui
travaillent tous les jeunes et moins
jeunes
les gens y travaillent dans la tête on
sent en plus de ça c'est un sens utile
de par l'action de la société
et puis bah ouais je vis un peu mur
parce que j'ai une poubelle
bon c'est pas non plus des mille et des
cents mais c'est mieux que le rsa ça
c'est clair
[Musique]